well good morning good evening
good good night uh wherever you're at
i thank you for checking in on this
fourth labyrinth
laboratory automation and dramatic
spiritual event
so i know this is a special time and i
really appreciate
uh labyrinths because they had forced
foresight
to know about uh the future in terms of
virtual versions of conferences and this
very trying times just to really
shows its power so so thank you again
uh thank you for staying up late if
you're in in the time zone that's uh
that's the
other side of the world so my name is
abe lee from uc irvine
as just introduced from biomedical
engineering also
around a research center and it's called
center for advanced design and
manufacturing of integrated
microfluidics
today my title my talk will be trying to
bridge the multi-skill physiological
systems via microfluidics
and and i'll talk a little about how it
scales from the single cell upwards for
organ cells also
how single cells itself can scale down
to the molecular scale
and next slide
so this is a brief overview of the
outline i
looked at the attendees list and i found
that you have a very diverse
i have a very diverse group of people
listening in
some of you are students some of you are
faculty some of you are researchers
at universities or at companies
and some of you are in sales some of you
are writers
your backgrounds from what i can tell
range from chemistry biology
engineering uh even non-science
so so it's it's a tough uh job for me to
try to
uh at least the first time i have to
address such a broad
and diverse audience i'll do my best and
um so here uh there's a quick uh
the outline including the ability to
try to introduce to you microfluidics as
a tool of the future
to bridge the multiple skills that that
form the complexity of biology
and of life itself and then i'll talk
about some examples
specifically on how we our lab has been
processing blood and trying to get
multiple scaling information from blood
and more recently it's a hot and
popular field in in cell engineering
immunotherapy
gene therapy uh we'll talk a little
about some effort
briefly about some efforts in my lab and
finally i talked about more of the scale
up
to the the larger systems but trying to
represent it
from a microphysiological system
so uh we these days we hear a lot about
precision medicine
and what that entails of course there's
a lot of promises
made in terms of how we can
have medicine pre-symptomatically
detect disease onset trying to
even just maintain the high quality of
life keeping our
system afloat in terms of
healthy and living a good life but
it boils down to truly trying to get
that target that and and i call it i i
coined it the minimal representative
unit mru
and there are two ways they look at this
the mru could be
if you look at a person on the left here
you see
um you may be a drop of blood or or a
tissue sample
you try to get the minimum sample that
has the target of interest
you know it could be the cancer cell it
could be the mutation the cancer dna
or it could be your glucose
level in terms of diabetics
so you're trying to get the minimal
sample that can predict
your health status your physiological
condition or for many cases just
fundamentally understand
physiology so minimal sample that's
called the top down
you're extracting the mru minimal
representative unit on the right hand
side there's the flip of it
which is if you want to build um up a
minimal
model that represents the whole system
not just take
just taking the sample will not do it
you want to be able to build
something that represents for instance
an organ like your eye or your
or your kidney or your brain or your
liver your colon
and by building that up understanding
some of the basic
structures and constituents that allow
you to
predict from that small tissue
or the small sample that you built up
from bottom up
what the body how the body would respond
accordingly
you would also be able to to generate
a bottom-up mru and
and what you see
in in these circles are different um
areas
of mru efforts meaning
current research and paradigms of
looking at trying to to tease out the
mru
eventually what precision medicine is
trying to do is come up with
um what people have um
sorry
the animation here is supposed to be
highlighting the top circle which is the
theranostics
which is pretty much combining
integrating diagnostics and therapy
so someone can
can at the same time detect a disease
coming onset
at the same time before it even develops
into symptoms
uh treatments happening and many of
these technologies are
allowing you to do that but my main
point here
is to say that microfluidics which is a
way that you can handle
samples at dimensions of so-called
10 to 100 microns in in terms of its
critical dimensions
is the scale that you manipulate the
single cell and if you can then
manipulate a single cell you can start
to project
extrapolate up and you can in terms of
multiple cells and how the cells
communicate and also downwards where a
single cell what it is
uh what it secretes what it expresses
and that tells you
single cell analysis tells you how each
of the cells are reacting so
microfluidics became a processor much
like the integrated circuits have
come for our computers uh eventually
linking it all
up to become the uh internet and and
internet of things uh here i i would say
that microfluidics has a chance to
rival that maybe even at a larger scale
because of complexity of biology and the
interest to improve life and that's main
purpose
so and i just put this slide briefly
just to say that there's a new paradigm
shift
recently as well with the 2018 nobel
prize winner
uh was on immunotherapy cancer
immunotherapy
and so this new paradigm is
takes from the past where medicine is
traditionally
trying to treat the symptom i think
immunotherapy
is a turning point where we now try to
really treat the root
of cause because the body is reacting
sometimes it's not
necessarily what's invading the body but
it's how the body reacts
and this interplay between
foreign invasion or or changes
to the body's response is the whole
system so
really it's something relatively new
relatively new in terms of
uh western medicine but in eastern
medicine of course we have a lot of
more holistic approaches and um
and more of the thought of the whole
body uh treatment is all connected
but immune this will this really change
because now we use
more modern science and and more modern
technologies
to look at the interplay so i i myself
as well as many groups in
the world with microfluidics are looking
at both sides how the body is responding
how how biological and analysis is
happening
hand in hand so
and uh i mentioned this quickly but i
would just still mention this the cell
is pretty much a mammalian cell
uh typically between 5 and 20
20 microns in general and the
microfluidic chips
in terms it is using similar to
integrated surface technology but it's
much a little larger because of the
um the steps that involve the third
dimension meaning the thickness of the
wafer
in the circuit you only have a very thin
film here you have a
third dimension so manipulating between
10 to 20 microns
is the sweet spot of microfluidics and
if you have
electrodes that are those dimensions you
can create gradients
and so the again the physics tells us
that we can manipulate cells and its
molecules
uh at ease with many of the current
improvements advancements of
microfluidics technologies
and so the bridging between the skills
that i mentioned throughout this time
i'm going to mention throughout the talk
bridges from the molecular skill up to
the
body skill and treatment and diagnostics
and that's because micropolis have
linkage you can scale up and scale down
and and this uh this is where
digital biology links to single cell
analysis
links to quantitative biology in
physiology
in ways that you can predict much more
precisely
ways to treat and diagnose
so i'm going to dive right into some of
the examples and technologies that my
lab has been pursuing
and the first one here is really
focusing on sample processing and some
subpopulation enrichment
and you'll see what i mean in the next
few slides
so i there are many different samples
that you can take from the body
but one of the primary ones is blood
blood is part of the circulatory system
whereas very very
useful and has a lot of information
because it circulates
you when you take a drop of blood it
might have gone through the whole
body in terms of its capillaries all the
different organs the peripherals
your brain your heart your lung it goes
through all these places
and if your body has any kind of change
in any
particular area that information gets
spread out
and conveyed and transported throughout
the body that's why it's so fascinating
to look at
blood and see what is the minimal volume
you can
process much like i mentioned the mru
that you need
for diagnosing or trying to detect
specific
changes and and hopefully down to the
molecular scale which gives you the
precision medicine
aspect this is very much
uh right in the sweet spot again of the
volumes that
microfluidics handles and we talk
typically
in terms of the microliters 50
100 micron microliters is is what we're
looking for in a drop of blood it has
about
a few millions maybe five to 10 million
cells the body has
30 trillion cells or so and so with
a small sample it's really small you
want to assure
yourself that it has a target it has a
minimal
it has the sample it has the information
that you want
and so it turns out that many of the
recent developments have told us
that we can we are able to detect
that what's happening
in the 30 trillion cells that are
circling through the body
uh with these few million cells in a
drop of blood
which is very exciting and but it
requires a lot a lot of
uh new technology development and
understanding
fundamental biology
so that is because blood has
is composed of consists of many many
different types of cells
and these cells have different functions
they interact with each other
they might take information from
a part of the body to another part
that will affect it like cancer cells
can transport
from if it's metastatic and transfer
from one side to another
which we want to understand how that
happens that's an example
and stem cell-like properties and and
how things change
are also triggered by the whole system
through the blood
circulation these are different types of
cells different sizes
again sweet spot of microfluidics is i
can take a drop of blood
and look at these individual components
and that's something that
many researchers including our lab has
been pursuing
however there has been recent
some of you may have learned about a
particular company
and that's featured in this book called
black bad blood
and i would just tell you that hopefully
that does not
contaminate or taint your impression of
this
exciting field what i want to say is
this this
company started very early my first
postdoc actually was hired to work at
that company and he left
after six months and they of course had
a lot of
problems scandals and ethic issues
most importantly they did not follow the
scientific method to pursue their
technology but
what i want to mention here is more
positive spin is that
they they raise a lot of money and
therefore there is a huge need and
desire
to be able to process blood and get
really small amounts of blood small
volumes of blood and get
a lot of information that helps your
health so there's a need there's a
desire and there's
money out there because they raised a
lot of money but
at the same time it really requires
technology new technology development
that they were not willing
to invest in and that kind of
is one of the keys to their downfall and
i
again you you can always think of um
people in scientifically they make their
best scientific guess but in my case
i think microfluidics held the key and
my postdoc was laid off because they
decided not to trust in microfluidics so
the new technology needs to be developed
uh to pursue this huge dream huge vision
um that was the original
motivation for that that company that
failed
so here i will um show one particular
technology called the lab
called the lateral cavity acoustic
transducer we call it lcat
in my lab and these pictures are
students
in the past that contributed to the
research so just want to know
knowledge their hard work their
creativity and their
their really strong ability to take
concepts and take it to
really they're contributing a lot into
the life sciences industry as we speak
like armando
so here i have an example of a
technology that i called
uh lcaps and it's based on a fundamental
physics
of acoustic micro streaming and there's
a paper published in 2003 that shows
that if you have inter
you have an interface an air liquid
interface this bubble here
that you see on the left top corner of
that picture if that's vibrating at a
certain frequency
the the fluid right next to the
interface will move
with that frequency however because the
fluid is by nature viscous and so this
viscous is your trans um
is able to um this viscous
shear is able to be transported to
farther away from the interface and this
discus has a secondary
second order transport
called acoustic streaming so that
results in these
this kind of a pattern of streaming
where far away from this small
little bubble uh you have a lot of we
have large motions of fluid
even though the liquid itself is only
the
air bubble is only moving a fraction of
this um
this dimension of that vortex so these
two vertices
resolved from that little bubble on the
right hand side
on top here would be a movie that shows
how particles will follow the trajectory
so i'm not going to show that movie
um but if we align on the bottom left
you can see if we align these bubbles
in the microfluidic channel and i and i
just try to explain here there's three
channels from the left
entering and merging into a center
channel
um the left the top and the bottom are
white
areas are air and the more greatest
areas are
liquid so if you plot if you put this
whole chip
on top of an acoustic trans transducer
or a piezo
a pct transducer
you will activate the air bubble
air liquid interface because of the
density difference that means the air
the sound travels at higher speeds
in the liquid and the density
difference causes them to really focus
the vibration at the interface
so i'm going to show the movies uh
okay you can see if i just the bottom
here is a acoustic
piezo on top is a is a microfluidic chip
i can
take a fluid from the left that uses
those kinds of
lcats that pushes fluid so it's a
pumping effect from the left chip to the
right chip
okay so
what you just saw was uh the right
bottom
um chip that has a cube that moves
fluids from one chip to another
i'm going to show another movie
would have seen is these little
particles will start to move and so
add up to be a pumping effect
and here is maybe a movie that might be
more interesting
so we again have these lateral um
planted channels that have dead end
bubbles trapped
and when you have that interface
vibrating because it's on top of the
piezo actuator
you create a microfluidic acoustic
streaming like i mentioned
earlier but because of this angle you
only have one
vortex on top and on bottom you can see
these
vortices and there's some red and green
cells representing cells colored dots
that are representing cells
they're trapped in those little vortices
the smaller pink
dots are particles that are small
and so they represent the fluid stream
if i look at
more detail of the movie you can see
more details that there is
that vortex that you can't speak
so in that movie that you just saw you
can see that the
air liquid interface at that interface
these cells
are are trapped in um the vortex
and there are small there are different
types of orbits that they are
taking and that's that will later on i
will explain that that will
dictate um in terms of the size that
they um
they actually orbit uh around uh is on a
is kind of separating in their size the
smaller ones are become
part of the pumping effect where it just
continues to go from left to right
so the significance of this technology
is such that you have a pump you have a
built-in pump that i showed in the
previous slide
you also have a trap a filter so larger
size
cells or particles can be trapped in
these vortices
along the microfluidic channel and as
the fluid moves from left to right
it filters out larger particles or it
filters
away smaller particles and traps larger
particles
and i can actually set the amplitude
such that different sizes of particles
get
trapped and released and therefore you
can sequence
serially a collect
the samples and downstream i can collect
them in different
size batches so that's
that's what the technology holds so you
can trap cells
okay so this this shows that if you put
instead of a fluid a general fluid like
i showed in the cartoon earlier
i put in blood and as i showed earlier
the blood has
all these different cells different
sizes it has plasma that has proteins
and lipids and other types of
uh molecules that are inside
uh the plasma itself so when we go so i
put blood this is whole blood actually
in our device
and we put it on top of acoustic
transducer
and i start to actuate it you can see
from the top
left the red blood and then the bottom
left
just the device itself i will show a
couple videos
but let me talk through it first bottom
one that's with the letter m6
and the right one m5 what we're going to
show is
whole blood moving through the channels
that are
in the surface serpentine fashion
and there will be red blood cells moving
slower or the
blood cells will move slower than the
plasma and they will separate
out as you collect them downstream
on
okay so as you can see uh
the blood the red part which has a lot
of the
red blood cells that's why it's red our
blood is red because of red blood cells
you can see that there is a front of the
fluid that's moving
that's a different color more
transparent color and that is the
uh the so-called plasma that's being
moved
faster because it's not trapping the
cells are actually the fluid is moving
faster and the red blood cells are being
trapped
after a while you'll see that if you put
particles in there they'll be trapped
or if you were able to look at the next
slide i'll show here
that this is whole blood no particles
are in there
over time you can have several steps but
over time this
on the left you see whole blood in the
middle you see
the intermediate stage where some of the
red bloods will continue to be
pumped but what you left behind are
larger cells
and in this case they're actually white
blood cells
actually i will show this movie because
it's important for many of the things i
can talk about
in the next other slides
so what you've seen there is the white
blood cells after a while where the red
blood cells are all filtered out
you have the white blood cells remaining
and
that that is a feature of this
technology that i mentioned very simple
concept you have a pump
and you have a trap that has this cut
off size and so you can trap
cells that are blocked a certain size
and this becomes very handy for many of
the applications that i will
be mentioning so when you look at blood
as an example you can take
in this case trying to spike
in different diameter particles in this
case 15 microns and 25 micron particles
at the end of the outlet you can see
that you have an enrichment
of those particles because originally
you have on the top there you see the
original 25 micro
meter fluorescent image you only see one
um
25 micrometer fluorescent speed a
particle
but after collection because you trap
them in those vertices and then you let
them go and you collect them
you see how much you enrich them so you
can reach them by 500 600 times
as you see on the graph on the left and
15 to 25 microns is somewhat
significant because that most of the
circulating tumor cells are larger in
size
in between 15 microns and 25 microns so
if you are able
to enrich for those particles so
initially being very very dilute like
you see
on the top right black box
it becomes much more easier to collect
many more in the sample if you can
enrich them into us
into the same volume of fluid
and just to demonstrate how it looks
like
you would see something to the effect of
this movie
so what you've seen in that movie there
is uh
are the very very few cells that we
trapped and it can be down to the
so-called
rear cell population rare cell typically
is is defined as
less than a thousand cells per
milliliter so when you have very few
cells
you want to be able to trap them you
want to be able to enrich them so you
can
do an analysis and diagnosis based on
another
another very useful way of using this is
you have a sample
and you have a specific population which
we sometimes call side populations
and they may have certain properties
like stem cell-like properties
they may develop into cancer or may have
have the markers for
metastasis is critical that you can
capture these cells but not only capture
these cells
but not disturb them because cells are
live entities they are
easily changing in how they respond
their states and so on so if you
use methods such as labeling and other
types of processing techniques
you may disturb its original state and
have it in
uh accurate diagnosis and in this
particular example here that we've
carried out we tried to look at a
specific du 145
cell line and their ranges of sizes cell
sizes are seven micron
to 28 microns and this is a
basically a prostate metastatic
cell that has mag has metastasized to
the brain
and we can pick that up as a marker as a
example marker for um for cancer
circling tumor cell or you can look at
just pure
from your healthy blood i can just try
to pick up the larger monocytes
and that has implications again for
stem-like properties or just
the immune system how it's responsive or
not in terms of the
macrophage developments
so breast cancer cells and we did the
different types of cells and we've shown
that we can get large
enrichment ratios which is simply the
target cell
over the um over the original
population of cells like in this case
white blood cells so you're trying to
enrich
uh from the background which is the
healthy cells
we've been able to get average size 18
mark we've been able to take from
patient blood and okay this case is the
spike one but later we did some patient
blood
and we were able to pick up 99
at least based on several experiments um
all of the rares the cell population
that we spiked in
and we're talking about 10 10
cells per milliliter and as you show in
this plot here and still getting a very
high enrichment ratio
sufficient for single cell analysis
so the next i'll talk quickly about is
okay the blood has all these components
constituents it has the cells it has the
plasma what do you do with
the rest of it and and my vision here is
to take blood
small sample of blood but look at the
whole spectrum the whole panel
uh what's expressed in the plasma what
kind of antibodies you have
uh what's in this white blood cells how
are these different white blood cells
activated or not
uh and red blood cells and so on so here
are some examples of that
other scale dimension so you have the
if i sequentially isolate the blood
cells i can look at
i can take the blood if you look at the
sample of blood
you see the whole blood on the top
and there are there are different cells
in there like i
the basic ones as we all know are the
plasma
the white blood cells and the red blood
cells so if i were able to if i can
separate out all the cells trap them in
our lcat
in those vertices that i showed earlier
um i can
look at just the platelet accounts
accounts and if you have too many
we can be an indicator of stroke or
heart attack and too few
again might mean your blood is not
clotting well you might have indications
of pointing towards possibility of
leukemia or lymphoma
if you look at the red blood cells if i
can separate out just the red blood
cells and
and look at them and if you look at
their morphology
you can start to see if you might have
indications of sickle cell or anemia
um sickle cell anemia or leukemia and
the white blood cells tell you a lot
about
your immune system autoimmune disorders
hiv
and if you have too many because you're
fighting cancer you might have again
tumor
or tb so these are five different
main types of white blood cell
leukocytes
that we've been able to take out and
stain
and identify and also prove their
viability
we can also just look at the analytes
but you typically go to a
doctor and take i draw blood we draw a
little bit too much blood in my opinion
and last time i went i have 50
milliliters of my blood taken
but the idea is that i want to compare
with the current standard practice
if our lcat takes blood and
separates out different components do
they match what the current
standard laboratory clinical laboratory
diagnostics tells us so we try to do
that
with centrifuge plasma which is typical
of a
clinical laboratory and in this case
look for different components i'm just
going to show a couple
one is glucose you look at patients
with different types of anticoagulants
and you'll see that they're very very
similar in the glucose levels that we
detect except for patient one
and there's always something anomaly or
some some some probably mistake that
we've taken but the red
is lcat and the the beige
or the greenish is
the centrifuge separated blood plasma
and if i look at the um and again very
important one
especially for current fighting of the
kelvin 19 is your antibody expression so
it really
igg is an example we can use our lcap to
separate out the plasma
and we look at the igt expression
concentration
and very very much the same as what you
get
with a drop of blood instead of cubes of
blood
getting the same kind of readout so this
is very assuring that our technology
does not do anything inadvertently
change the figures or change the
quantity of the analytes of interest
and specifically for viral detection
i'm showing a quick example of using the
basic
functions of lcat the pumping and the
mixing
because you create vortices that also
creates a rapid mixing
which is very difficult in microfluidic
devices so we show here
the device that are able to look at
continuous monitoring of co-infections
by hsp hpv and hiv in patients so in
hsp and hpv in hiv-positive patients so
which means that if you have hiv
it's very it's women especially women
very likely to
develop hpv which is which is also very
very
dangerous because it can cause cancer
uh herpes or um a virus
so we use this device here in
collaboration with anagen discovery inc
to rapidly detect multiple analytes
that indicate co-infection which is very
difficult to do with other technologies
so we have a panel of 156
antigens from hiv hsp hpv
and control which is the pinkish one and
we looked at
trying we looked at trying to take
the plasma and put it in this device and
pump it through and
rapidly mix it so that you can get these
signals
and this next slide shows the reactivity
of hiv positive
comparing serum and saliva it's very
very similar
so for hiv positive patients we have
very accurate readout from the saliva
it was not as accurate and we're still
working on in hsp and hpv
but nonetheless we use if we use just
the serum it's very accurate
we can then look at hiv hpv
fuel patients and so so this is very
important because once you have hiv
what happens is typically your immune
system is obviously compromised
and so your readout of other types of
antibodies will not be as accurate but
having multiple
antigens allows you to tease out that
information and quick and be more
precise in detecting
these diseases that kind of interplay
and i mentioned how complex it is
where your immune system is fighting one
disease and if you develop another
disease
you can't use the immune system is
compromised you cannot
accurately diagnose in some cases the
other diseases that are co-infections
so just comparing serums for hiv as you
can see
the pads and the different um
the levels of of the
intensity is very very similar
um so this is a platform that we are
we've been able to
to do something that typically takes
three to four hours in
in the lab setting down to about less
than 20 minutes
we are also able to really
compare hiv-positive serum and saliva
samples
and also see that they have significant
reactivity with both hsv hpv which
tells why they can be difficult to
diagnose at the same time so you need a
multi-collective assay that we just
developed here
um and we're developing these
serodiagnostic markers so you can take
it to the field
and do rapid diagnosis we are also
working on converting this platform
for the current to fight the current
stars lv2
i will uh talk a little bit about a
couple other examples switching gears
because once you take a lot of like
trillion millions of cells at least
down to a handful or in some cases
thousands of cells
you can now have a much more manageable
popular sub-population
like what we call it to to more
accurately
read out what um condition is and what
we use is this
a new this area that's taken off in the
last
10 years which is a single cell analysis
so if you take blood for example you
might
try to separate out the the cell of
interest but then the size overlap a lot
the white blood cells healthy ones and
leukemia cells are very similar in size
so in order not to have false negatives
you want to
collect all of the cells that are
white blood cells and above and that's
what the right hand side of graph is
showing just overlapping the size
and and we can also sort them based on
their markers
so these are ways that currently are
being used
what we want to show you is that trying
first of all trying to
trying to first enrich for the cell
target
interest sub population and then being
able to
do single cell analysis that
distinguishes between healthy white
blood cells and
cancerous leukemia cells that look very
similar
from the eye in some cases but let me
just show you
a video
so what you just see you just saw there
in that video
is it's not for leukemia in that case
but it's just demonstration of a
single cell array trap and this has been
developed by others
including hang lua at georgia tech but
we adopted it for this particular
application where we can trap
take blood that's already
already enriched to some degree and
filter out the rest of red blood cells
through these microfluidically
microfabricated
traps and capture larger cells anything
above a white blood cell we capture
into these single cell trapping arrays
and
and then you can see we can capture
white blood cells with overlapping
diameters as shown in the bottom right
graph
on the left graph you can see when the
fluid flows back and forth in these
channels
the larger cells get trapped eventually
forming an array of single cells
and if you were to expand this because
microfabrication technology can be
easily scaled up you get this kind of a
larger scale single cell analysis so i
can take a volume of blood
and enrich for a subpopulation
and then trap every cell that might be
suspicious
uh we can go all the way up to about 100
000 cells single cell traps
and i collaborate with dr michelle
digman and her
former phd student lingama and we work
we work to try to do label free
metabolic identification of these cells
that are trapped
and so what we launched they have a
technology called fluorescence lifetime
imaging microscopy
because of time i won't go into much
detail you can look up their papers
the idea is that there are there is an
intrinsic metabolite
nadh and if it's bound
um or an unbound you will have a
different lifetime
that can be indicated by this the
lifetime of the fluorescence
um that it emits and that lifetime
itself is represented by this so-called
phaser plot
the easier way to look at it is it
shifts from red to green to the bottom
right
graph here in terms of going from a more
oxford
more healthy cell-like metabolism to a
more
glycolytic metabolism
in terms of the greenish so we look at
that signature to indicate whether a
cell is healthy
or cancerous and with that we are
actually able to take that blood
separate out the white blood cells and
identify
these plots that show the signatures
of different types of white blood cells
and leukemia cells
these are typical ones that are k562
um or jircat or php1 they have different
features so not only can you separate
between healthy white blood cells
and leukemia cells but you can also
separate from the different types
of leukemia cells and each of these dots
indicate a single cell
signature from its blim analysis
and metabolism it's pretty much the
metabolic state so i can separate
i can take the cancer patient i can try
to monitor
its cancer cells if you have treatment
you can monitor the treatment as well
and so now we combine the two the
microfluidic trap and the
microfluidic trap here that can capture
and filter
in size based and combine it with this
phaser
metabolic flim detector it has a very
powerful screening tool
so if you have a single cell trap now
you have easy access to the single cells
that are already extracted from a large
population um i
you might say label free is still prone
to some mistake because there's some
it's more complicated you want to be
very
very sure uh what the genetic
the genotype is or the expression level
is so we
also work with dr kumar with graham
singh
he has an afm tip that he can go and we
developed a microfluidic tip compatible
with it
so you can go and probe and go inside
the cell
that's trapped in a microfluidic chip
and apply
the so-called dielectrophoresis and
extract out
the mrna and that gives you a signature
based on qpcr so i can actually
now detect if you have
either the housekeeping genes which is a
good control
or uh cert like cd45 more indicative of
white blood cells and her2 in terms of
breast
cancer uh afghan more metastatic state
detection so with this you have a
powerful tool from the single cell level
to go
from metabolic physiological states down
to
more of the genetic expression state
this i won't go too too much but show
you a cartoon may be
good you can see if i can combine this i
can
expand this single cell trap to look at
cell to cell interaction
i can flow in one direction and trap one
type of cell
and flow in the other direction trap
another type of cell that's the red cell
and put them together to look at their
communication between the two cells and
that could be important
because immune immune synapses and other
types of synapses
rely on cell cell contact or at least
the vicinity
so you have this synaptic paracrine
signaling
so you can you can use this kind of
device to study whether cells to sell
can be activated
and you can also trap them so you can
you can start to culture them
in situ it shows
some results this is actually a probably
pretty early data that i'm showing you
here green and red they're
showing on the top right side
so one of the areas that in my lab is
becoming
more and more prevalent is this notion
of
cell engineering and i'm just going to
show a few slides with some of the
attempts
because i'm so fascinated by this
immunotherapy and how t
cells are activated how anagen
presenting cells
um are able to gobble up the end
of the the foreign cells
and you only express the um
the antigen peptide uh on its uh
on its mhc or its antigen presenting
molecule
uh and this interaction between t cell
tumor cell
and and and dendritic cell is just
they're just so many interesting things
they also can
have cytokines uh trigger out and
eventually have the t
cell and the b cells um and there's also
the
recent adopted cell therapy which or or
you have this car key which allows you
to take
a patient a sample and
try to harvest and expand for t cells
specific for the tumor and and has very
very tremendous results
that saved a lot of lives what can
microfluidics do
here um so one thing we try to do is try
to mimic that energy presenting cell
creating artificial cells and we're
working on trying to do it for
cancer therapy but here we show a simple
demonstration of that and that is trying
to create
a beta cell synapse or for insulin
secretion so some of the
diabetic patients require stimulation of
the
their beta cells for more influence
secretion so we're able to show that
this
fluid membrane that's made out of
microfluidic technology
can artificial cell can trigger a real
biological cell
another way of demonstrating cell
engineering
is this lipoplex technology which is a
way to use
cationic lipids with complexes
with the dna that you want to deliver
for gene therapy for example
creating these lipoplex nanoparticles we
were able to create
a platform microfluidic platform that
mixes together
cells and the reagent liquefecting
very rapidly into these microfluidic
droplets the droplets then
will encapsulate the single cell and the
reagents
and rapidly mix so you have uniform
sizes of the particles and uniform
delivery into the cells
and as a result this technology it's
kind of
pretty sophisticated there you can see
that we were able to get a big shift
in terms of from bulk
uh the bulk method bulk lip perfection
versus drop it with liquefaction bulk is
the
pink in the grass and the yellow is the
droplet lip effect so you can see a huge
difference
in its fluorescent intensity and very
uniform as well
and uh we showed that we can
can we can transfect uh plasmid
for instance gfp very uniformly into
so-called suspended cells like those
leukemia cells that we showed earlier
and very uniformly
and at high efficiency so bulk ones get
five percent of the transfection
typically
we with our early tests we were able to
get 10 times better
in delivery so this is very promising
where microfluidics can play a huge role
in delivery and transfection of cells
and we use this and i won't go into
detail but you might have heard
of a gene a gene editing tool that's
taking off
called crispr cas9 we use the same
method to show that we can also edit
part of the gene in the cell single
cells with this technology
last last kind of example i was showing
using using lcat again
you remember the cell swirling at those
vortices
i can use that technology as well to
deliver
cargo into the cells and or you can
label cells so
the beauty again is i can trap cells i
put in
different types of watching regions that
are pumped through there
and they're uniformly mixed and swirling
at the same time i can deliver reagents
that go in
or on outside of the cell
so it can be a really efficient way to
manage in cell engineering
and it just shows that in situ for
staining of cells we can do the same
thing
staining of cells with elcap versus
standard you can see very
much the same kinds of intensities that
you get
from both so
we're this is an area that's still
ongoing we're hopeful to show more
results in the coming year
okay and um this asm tip we are also
working with dr kumar rick graham
cindy to uh to deliver things in
with two minutes or so i'm going to just
quickly mention the last
part of my presentation which is this
vascularized micro organs
and i collaborate i started by steve
george and chris hughes
my two colleagues um steve george at uc
davis chris
hughes at uc irvine one's vascular
biologist one's a tissue engineer
we ca we started out 10 years ago to try
to
recapitulate the connective tissue that
has
blood vessels so if we have an artery
the red
artery that's connected at the tissue
level to the blue
veins or the venules there's capillary
vessels in between and so can we recap
if you have
drug discovery and normally with a 2d
like on bottom
you see normal models are 2d cell
cultures
um the other extreme is the total human
and in between there are animal models
or spheroids
but one thing that's lacking either is
it's the complexity of this physiology
um or the blood vessels the mouth may
have blood vessels
but they have very different metabolic
and other types of systems that
that cause us not to be as precise in
prediction
so we developed something that might use
your own human cells
developing a platform for you to test
for drugs
so here you see um the result and i
would if we had i would be able to show
let me show
so you see that we
were able to show that we grow tissue
with uh blood vessels in there and the
those little green particles are moving
inside the vessels so what happens on
the bottom one that you saw
a confocal image that's turning around
is blood vessels
infiltrating a tumor little tumor and so
if you deliver
drugs through the vasculature it
recapitulates how drugs are delivered
if you are undergoing chemotherapy and
predicts better
with vessels how the blood the tumors
would grow
versus without the blood vessels
so we are excited about this technology
we even started a company
that that's called ericari biosciences
and
and um the three of us are co-founders
as well and we're trying to develop a
platform that can use it for drug
screening
so to kind of summarize my talk i showed
you a lot of technology
maybe too many things um but how you can
process
for the mru which is the minimal
representative unit
for precision medicine closing the loop
and what we're closing is
not only the loop from the scale from
molecular scale to
the um from the molecular skill
to the body skill from the health skill
but also from diagnostics to treatment
i think microfluid holds the key the
critical key
that connects the skills and connects
these um
being able to see it holistically
because you capture and you have precise
tools to analyze and it's much like
looking at a drawing you either look for
a waldo
which is um which might be in this
picture that's the top down looking at
the minimal representing unit from top
down
or you take a painting and just crop out
a little part
uh and try to predict can i look at how
these
dots are put together to predict what
this painting is
what a painter is and that's another
practice that's more like the organ on a
chip
project that i showed at the end
and like seven da vinci shows studied
science of art studied art of science
uh we are trying to develop ways to see
science and art and that's like
fundamental science and technology
go hand in hand and i think is really
good representation of how
biomedical engineering is playing out
i'm also
live on chip editor-in-chief it's those
either academicians out there
these are some thematic collections and
the thought leaders
uh if you're interested you may contact
us in terms of trying to submit your
papers to this journal
you can also run the the cadmium
research center and a lot of companies
are involved if you're a company
interested in acquiring joining our
center please contact me as well
finally i want to just give recognition
to my very hard-working and talented
students
and funding sources and all my
collaborators
thank you very much and i look forward
to receiving your questions and having
more discussions